[Music]
time
like mother like daughter Pink's
daughter Willow heart rocking the crowd
just like her grammy-winning mama
[Music]
you're dressed up in pink saying their
2021 duet cover me in sunshine on the
opening night of Pink's summer carnival
tour in Bolton England
[Music]
[Applause]
her dad Carrie Hart posting the magical
moment on Instagram writing so proud of
Wills to get up on stage with Mama must
be a surreal moment
so sweet she's so unaffected and it's
not even something she wants to do I
asked her I said do you want to take
singing lessons she's like no I'm
already good at it this isn't the first
time Willow performed live with Mom
remember this moment from the 2021
Billboard Awards she joined pink in the
air for some acrobatics I want to be
the best mom in the world and I want my
kids to see what it looks like
to have a mom that's a boss a boss both
on the stage and off pink tells E.T
Willow has also been working behind the
scenes of her tour mostly she just
climbs on things and then gets paid for
not paying attention yeah have you two
finalized her rate we have we're going
off of minimum wage okay that's fair but
she doesn't want to pay taxes because
it's not for real so trying to teach her
if she wants to know the real world then
I'm also teaching her how to negotiate
for herself
we're working on it your amazing mom
[Applause]
Willow celebrated her 12th birthday on
Saturday and pink shared a sweet post to
celebrate
my darling my lovely unique brilliant
odd little duckling I Am So Into You I
carry your heart with me go get him
tiger how how proud of your mommy are
you
[Music]
[Applause]